what's going on guys
Fantastic Four has hit theaters with a
fantastic good whether you didn't like
it or really didn't like it you gotta
admit there's some pretty cool science
in there that's why we've called upon
our resident physicist dr. Clifford V
Johnson to come in and discuss the movie
science of Fantastic Four flame on
we are here with our good friend
returning to the show dr. Clifford V
Johnson dr. Johnson great to see you
again oh is the pleasure to be here I am
very angry at you because you wanted to
talk about Fantastic Four and that means
I had to see it you made me see this
movie dr. so sorry about that and for
even though I forgive you you're such a
good friend of the show you're so kind
to us you're so kind to me pleasure to
be here the movie science of Fantastic
Four give us some initial thoughts on
the film it started so well and they
sort of never got out of the start in a
way the movie just kept being in the
start phase and then sort of crumbled
terribly at the end interdimensional
travel what's up with that the idea is
actually rooted in something that I
actually worked on not the travel aspect
but certainly the idea of alternate
universes that you could maybe see
signatures of what's the difference
between an alternate universe and an
alternate dimension so I think it's
better to use the phrase alternate
universe in a sense that they were using
it what you have is an additional
dimension additional direction you could
go in and then you can place additional
universes in that direction I didn't
understand that they all take a book you
know old school book with pages sure
know what that is right what you then
have is the possibility that there are
other pages right next to each other oh
sure flip flip flip right and they're in
a direction that isn't one of the
directions you can move in normally in
our universe so that's the other
dimension parallel universes parallel
pages so there's hundreds of universes
so what they're playing with is the idea
that you can create a thing a machine
that could somehow jump you from one
page to the other how possible
is it to for a science student to create
something that advanced no one currently
is able to create such a thing
if such universes exist we don't know
probably if it were possible it require
so much energy that it's probably not
accessible to us and certainly not a
high school kid more believable the
cosmic rays or the alternate dimension
origin story because now cosmic rays are
somewhat more ordinary in our
imagination than perhaps they were in
the sixty dot check it maybe make sense
to play with something a little more
arcane like going to a different
universes and what I was hoping they
would play with is is is the idea that
maybe if they go to a place where the
laws of physics are different and then
you bring some of that back to our
universe and there's your basis for
superpowers right yeah physics is I'm
sure but the laws of physics were pretty
much the same on that planet right
except the the green blue stuff but
what's that green goo stuff don't know
give me your best guess some sort of
exotic matter that is somewhat unstable
and it's full of potential for giving
weird superpowers to people who touch it
but somehow not necessarily hurting them
let's shift gears and talk about the
individual powers at each of them attain
mr. fantastic they'll call mr. fantastic
but stretchy-arm miles teller is really
helped with his drumming actually yes
right no get a drum oh wait over here
now how does the physics of stretching
your limbs like that work is there
something that could happen to my arm
and I bones my legs where they could
stretch and come back
he wasn't conserving mass very well
which means that he was stretching quite
a lot but it wasn't thinning out so
right preserving the amount of stuff
he's made of and that bothered me a
little bit yeah because if you stretch a
rubber band it gets thinner and things
that way yeah I even I could understand
that
yeah the Human Torch the physics of
being on fire flame on flame off like a
light switch let's not worry about the
source the idea that it can be turned on
and off is kind of fun they seem to give
us some indication that he needs help to
do that with his suit to control yes
control II on and off this is constantly
burning but the suit helps and then he
goes flame on and he seemed to do
something with his hands
testing that there's some sort of
ignition maybe I read too much into that
they didn't need to do that the thing
got in that transporter with a bunch of
rocks
from the alternate universe came back to
our universe boom he's a rock man is
that the same science that caused
Brundle to get in a transporter with a
fly and become brundlefly the argument
you could make let's help them again
yeah is that somehow the teleportation
device must have confused Ben Grimm's
material up would get with the wrong
with the roxxon's and maybe it got a
little help from the strange stuff
that's over there maybe the strange
matter somehow helps their biology
survived that trauma and somehow
incorporated into the ball it was a life
giving it was yeah it enhanced them it
enhances them somehow but even gets
mostly the the transporters fault I
actually need to address the most
important thing about the thing yes he
needs pants is it the view of the entire
scientific community that the thing
needs pants I can't speak on their
behalf but that would be my guess for
the record for the record that's my
guess let's talk kate mara Invisible
Woman how does that work the force field
is is sort of a clue okay and again
let's let's help them get the physics to
work yeah they need it maybe what she's
doing is bending light around her and by
the way oh we need to come back to this
okay because she never actually went she
never where no I know nothing she got
blast and what jerks she's one of the
engineers and they don't take her stupid
miles teller took his friend Ben Grimm
it wasn't even a scientist instead of
the woman who was imperative to
everything they were doing absolutely
but last year her power bending light so
yeah so I would say let it all the force
field so what she's actually doing to
get invisible is she's bending the light
around it so you're looking for example
you're looking at me right now and so
I'm getting in the way of the stuff
behind me so you can't see it
mmm if I were able to bend the light
from that stuff around me so it comes
yeah bends around and then continues on
its path then you wouldn't see me oh so
maybe that's what she's doing and she's
doing it with a force field and she can
also use those force fields to
black staff and make other things
invisible so you need one thing the
force field ability to explain all her
powers as opposed to a separate thing
for the force field and a separate thing
for her invisibility and what have you
let's talk about dr. doom what were his
powers what happened to him he was in an
alternate universe for how long a year
goes by right when they you know there's
a thing and then a year later they can
all use their powers and what-have-you
and so we assume that a year goes by on
Planet whatever and it occurred to me
that maybe you didn't go by maybe it's a
day for him it could have been you know
they disappeared and then 10 minutes
later they came back from where did he
get that cloak okay that's right the
cloak come from yeah well what's the
physics behind manifesting a cloak well
given that he was endowed with pure
randomness in his powers and abilities
making a cloak actually it's not that
much of a challenge probably endowed
with pure randomness okay like that did
you just cop out on me did you just say
there's no rhyme or reason
then he's inexplicably doing fisticuffs
Reed Reed Richards right yeah whereas a
few minutes earlier back on good old
home earth he was just looking at people
and they were exploding yeah exploded
ahead in the hallway okay so what's the
science behind that okay let's help them
okay I'm having a thought let's help
them you've never said let's help them
in regards to any movie more than you've
said it about pasta for in this episode
think I see yeah okay maybe the UH the
blue green stuff yeah is more powerful
when it's further away maybe what's
happening is that he's able just to look
at people and explode and doors burst
open them yeah I walls what have you
right because the matter that he's he's
playing with there it's just so amenable
to that because he's controlling it with
the blue green stuff yeah but then when
he goes back he has to you know do punch
oh yeah it's like oh dang fields evil
I just made that up I know physics is
your area of expertise but I'm going to
ask you a chemistry question okay what
could we have done to improve the
chemistry of the four lead actors
probably they being old talented actors
could also not see a hell of a lot of
motivation on the page and so they just
weren't bringing it and the end result
how would you describe it train wreck
what stories regarding the Fantastic
Four have you read or had you imagined
that we're not present well it's not a
particular story per se it's a certain
tone yes what I saw from the trailer was
a sort of a little bit of an indie sort
of darkness bringing that to exploring
other universes and things like that and
then bringing that here yeah would be a
thing that hasn't really been done
imagine you took some of the visual and
imagination playfulness of interstellar
yeah and brought that to Fantastic Four
rather than trying to fit it into a
gritty realistic so it's fiction film
which you know we could argue about yeah
you bring it to wild imagination of a
Marvel comic mm-hmm that I would like to
see that movie has not been made yet
right it should be made and the
Fantastic Four would have been the place
to do it that was the place where Kirby
was playing with ideas from physics or
wherever he got them from he was
bringing that into the comics blowing
the minds of a lot of young readers
myself included for all I know a little
piece of that helped me go into physics
and now I work on the real physics of
particles and dimensions and things like
that that is so cool right so wouldn't
that be great to see and then be amazing
you're like pissing me off because I'm
just thinking about the possibilities
nothing like they just the gravity was
the same gravity the same the air was a
so yeah ridiculous Wow
so many missed opportunity what I'm
talking about dr. Johnson I want to
thank you again for coming in and
talking Fantastic Four Oh was a pleasure
absolutely well that was a good time so
what would you like to see happen with
the Fantastic Four should they go back
to Marvel Studios let us know in the
comments section below
best answer we're gonna send you screen
junkies t-shirt I want to thank you for
watching I want to thank our awesome
guest dr. Clifford V Johnson I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye-bye
I have a feeling that that shootout
that's going on in the bridge is just a
one scene in the movie but I could be
wrong be sure I cannot be sure a bridge
fool um yeah a bridge